manger du homard à la fête des mères
c'est un classique mais évidemment le
cycle naturel de ce crustacé ne connaît
pas notre calendrier des chercheurs à la
demande de certains pêcheurs des
îles-de-la-madeleine se demande donc si
on ne devrait pas venu préciser les
dates de la saison de pêche pour
s'assurer d'avoir du homard pendant
encore de nombreuses années
[Musique]
sphérique orange et verte cette petite
boule mesure près de 2 mm de diamètre
c'est un oeuf de homard des îles de la
madeleine
en noir un oeil se dessine
cette offre contient beaucoup
d'informations comme la date de ponte
sadate d'éclosion et la date idéale de
la fin de la saison de pêche
nous sommes à bord du lay dicharry
nicolas et son équipe commencent leur
pêche
longues journées à remonter des caches
d'armes
[Musique]
quant à 39 troll qu'on appelle c'est
cette quasi attaché boutabout factuel
après l'autre qui change la peau tu
prends un moment avec la magie qu'on a
les femelles revêtu les amener dans
l'eau les romands au delà de jeux
pensait 83 mm à mesure tu peux les
garder et puis tout nouveau le stan
honey si une mesure pour les romands ce
qui est plus gros que la mesure qu'on
nous faut les remettre à l'eau aussi ils
disent que ça serait comme des bons
géniteur fait de même salle ou si peu la
ressource
pour assurer la durabilité de la
ressource le nombre de pêcheurs est
aussi limité
les ils comptent exactement 3 125
pêcheurs de homard le même nombre de
puits des décès chacun dispose de 273
quasi
la saison commence début mai selon des
critères bien précis déterminés par
pêches et océans canada de concert avec
les pêcheurs la recette qu'on a prouvé
aux élites qui est appliquée c'est le
samedi le plus près du death mais sans
le dépose
je veux dire explique fluence le plus la
journée normale de la mise à l'eau ce
raisonnement c'est le dragage dans
l'équipe tchèque
dépendamment de la température pour que
la chaussée 1 et le temps de faire des
pôles de pêche sécuritaire
les fidèles numéro deux c'est la vitesse
du vent si le matin de l'ouverture de la
pêche les prévisions sont au dessus de
20 noeuds on reportera l'ouverture de la
pêche
[Musique]
la saison se terminera neuf semaines
plus tard
et pour assurer la durabilité de la
ressource et la rentabilité de leur
pêche une des deux associations de
pêcheurs le rassemblement des pêcheurs
et pêcheuse des côtes des îles aimerait
que la biologie du homard devienne un
critère pour déterminer et dates de la
saison pêche ça tout a été dit que l'eau
n'ont donné l'état plus froide trop seul
enfin qu'après sommet dépendamment aux
normes ouverts tard des arts et en danse
à retarder la date un peu que l'eau soit
le plus chaud tandis que du côté sud
celle inverse
[Musique]
cachée sous des roches depuis des mois
le homard commence à bouger à avoir faim
et à devenir capturables lorsque la
température de l'eau atteint un point 5
degrés celsius
cette température est sur toutes les
lèvres des homardiers depuis les années
90 seulement voilà ce chiffre reste à
confirmer scientifiquement
enfin quant à diaw a assez il allait
chercher les données en temps réel tout
savoir quand ce que l'on m'a en plan dit
c'est un projet qu'on la montée puis on
a embarqué avec mélinand conjointe de
mal et du sang puis c'est la cinquième
année cette année
[Musique]
pour comprendre ce qui influence le
réveil du homard à la fin de l'hiver les
scientifiques de mairie 9 mesure la
température de l'eau en temps réel
il utilise des capteurs placés sur des
bouées répartis tout autour des îles et
on va prendre des mesures dans la
colonne d'eau près de la surface à 4
mètres de profondeur mais aussi sur les
fonds de pêche ses environs à 21 mètres
de profondeur normalement la façade nord
se réchauffe un peu plus lentement que
la façade sud donc le patron des
captures est pas exactement le même
pour corréler la température de l'eau et
la capture habilitées du homard et
scientifique pêche à leur tour ils
déploient des casiers pendant les trois
semaines précédant le début de la saison
on pêche
on va faire un dénombrement des homards
qu'il ya dans chacune des cages ont volé
mesurer les sexy donné leur état
métaboliques ou si c'est à dire c'est
que leur niveau protéines dans les eaux
membres puis à partir de ces mesures là
on est capable de dire le rendement de
capture commercial parcage es2 tel non
plus que le taux de protéines et aux
saveurs développement et plus on cherche
plus que lentement et l eau table pour
la compagnie qui achètent puis mulhouse
aussi comme résolue blier meilleur
[Musique]
pour l'instant ce qu'on remarque
vraiment c'est que la fameuse notion
seuil du de capture habilité durement le
1.5 degrés c'était une très bonne
d'estimation mais la réalité est
probablement beaucoup plus complexe est
ce que le homard revient rapidement dans
un mode où il cherche à s'alimenter ou
est ce que c'est quelque chose qui est
beaucoup plus graduelle c'est vraiment
de ce côté là qu'on va commencer à
regarder pour la suite du projet pour
essayer d'avoir une bonne idée de l'état
métaboliques sont morts avant l'hiver
qui vaut probablement mieux expliquer
donc là sa reprise au printemps
ces données pourrait aider à déterminer
la date d'ouverture de la pêche
mais pour déterminer la date de
fermeture de la saison il n'est plus
question de température mais de
reproduction
pour assurer la pérennité de l'espèce si
un pêcheur capture une femelle avec des
oeufs il doit la remettre à l'eau mais
une femelle capturer sans eux pourraient
encore se reproduire l'année suivante ce
qu'on ait cette phase est de cibler les
périodes où on va avoir le moins
possible de re capture de ces femelles
pour l'essai une chance aux stocks de se
sauver généreux pour estimer la date
d'éclosion des oeufs les scientifiques
font appel aux pêcheurs pour les
prélever en mer seuls deux sont
habilités à le faire dans le fond ça
fait depuis trois ans que je fasse avec
mais riner puis je prends les femelles
j'enlevais avec une pince et il en parle
comme d'une centaine 2 par femelle que
je mette à l'impôt avec du lourd face au
métal en glacière moi je ramène celui-ci
piezo d'état capable par la suite de
faire des prélèvements
[Musique]
nous à partir de cellules au fur et à
mesure de la saison on veut établir le
stade de développement des e mais on
fait aussi des mesures de la taille de
l'oeil de chaque oeuvre par rapport à la
mesure de l'ofs en tant que tel
puis c'est vraiment cessé rasulo de
l'oeil sur la taille de l'offre qui nous
permet de dire que les eaux vont éclore
dans une semaine ou deux semaines ou
trois semaines
ainsi les chercheurs ont constaté que
beaucoup d'eux est close avant la fin de
la saison de pêche ce qui augmente les
probabilités de capturer les femelles
sont ceux dans un optique de
développement durable ça pourrait être
une bonne idée de devancer la saison de
quelques jours si si l'objectif c'est de
ne pas aller repêcher des femelles dans
les yeux en déjà éclos c'est vraiment du
côté pêche océan sa décision
l'entreprise un coup qu'on a eu la
démonstration qu'on a une bonne
compréhension de ce qui se passe à
présent c'est de reprendre ces éléments
scientifiques lé de les interpréter avec
l'industrie pour arriver à quelque chose
opérationnel
[Musique]
une des stratégies serait de diviser la
zone de pêche les îles de la madeleine
comme ils l'ont fait en gaspésie je sais
pas comment est ce que ça pourrait
interpréter que une zone comme ans
tandis que lowe's on n'a pas commencé
encore pour une petite et je me fiche
pas ce que je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de
10,4 par rapport à ça je pense que la
force des îles de cette capacité à se
mobiliser et d'avoir cette discussion le
difficile même si des fois bon ça ça
génère de la charette cd discussion qui
doit avoir lieu qui doivent être faites
ensemble par toute l'industrie pour
s'assurer justement que l'équité entre
pêcheurs et préservé puis que la
solution
semble adéquat pour une bonne partie des
penchants
lola de chaussée en bonne santé on a
doublé quasiment triplé se complaire à
blogolo x 100 m enfin que ça vaut quand
même bien vous les entreprises de base
ben c'est tout le temps
alix à chaque année le mans et hulot le
prix et lots
les études se poursuivent pour que
l'explosion de la ressource de ces
dernières années se maintiennent le plus
longtemps possible
en comprenant mieux le comportement du
homard